hello everyone welcome back to the thing
it's your house Nord in this video I'll
be taking you through all the juicy
details we can expect in the new season
of Dance Moms
that's right guys Dance Moms will be
back for season 8 with a whole new set
of fresh faces and competitive little
dancers for all the confirmed newcomers
that you guys can expect to see and all
the latest drama on Abby and the og team
you guys that it keep on watching
nothing quite screams drama like the
past seven seasons of The Dance Moms
world many fans have always speculated
the drama to be either set up by
producers or completely blown out of
proportion except this time the
off-screen drama is giving it a run for
its money
Abby Lee has always been the face of the
series since it aired almost seven years
ago so fans everywhere we're pretty
shocked to hear that she was sentenced
to 366 days in prison for bankruptcy
fraud things then took a devastating
turn for the worst when fans received
the news that Abby was also battling
cancer as well at this point Abby had
already sworn off of Dance Moms and even
called out the producers of the show she
said that she was being manipulated
disrespected and used by men who had
never taken a dance lesson in their
lives and treated women like dirt now
while Abby speech was pretty convincing
she is actually confirmed to be back on
a Dance Moms seen starring in season 8
she's going to be joined by her new
competitive team that she's already
confirmed on her Instagram before we get
started on the different backstories
behind all the dancers here are some fun
facts about the upcoming season this is
going to be the first season of the show
that does not feature any of the
original cast this will now break me on
Hartley's seven seasons streak of
appearances on the show - fan favorites
who will also not be returning our
Eliana Wamsley who was part of the minis
group and Maci case this is probably
because Eliana will be too busy starring
on Dancing with the Stars jr. and
following all of her Broadway dreams as
for Macy she isn't doing too bad herself
and even says that she has no bad blood
with Abby at all she posted a very sweet
message her Instagram saying that she
was very grateful for Abby and all of
her time on Dance Moms this
being asked to return for a season each
you will be moving on from the lifetime
series to pursue some bigger projects
even though we've got to say goodbye to
most of our favorite original dancers
there is still definitely a story to be
told and more drama to unfold some of
the questions we can't wait to see
answered are things like will Abby be a
changed person after everything she's
been through will any of the OGS make a
guest appearance and will we be getting
any closure on Abby's relationships with
all of the previous dancers and their
moms I want to know what some of your
burning questions are so be sure to
leave them in the comments section I'll
be sure to check them out if you really
want to grab our attention be sure to
leave your favorite dance emoji next to
your comment this one's definitely my
fav now in one of Abby's post she
mentions that filming will be taking
place back in the original studio in
Pittsburgh she also warns that the new
dancer should be prepared to withstand
the pittsburgh cold to make it to the
final cut that's right guys Abby is back
with her everyone's replaceable attitude
watch especially seeing as all the
confirmed dancers have still got to earn
their Abby Lee dance company official
jackets and we all know how long that
can take another detail of the show that
has many fans upset is the fact that
Abby chose to hold open call auditions
for her show instead of choose dancers
from her actual studio as you guys might
have noticed from the season 8 roster
the dancer she has chosen we're already
very involved in the dance world unlike
the previous girls most of them already
have tons of experience in the
entertainment industry aside from the
Lee catchman who made her dance skills
very well-known from her season 7
debuted as a mini dancer yes 13 year old
Giannina from New Jersey who is a
perfect example of this and has already
starred in a ton of production this
includes working on the Broadway show
Matilda dancing for Mariah Carey at the
Rockefeller Christmas tree lighting and
even joining Mariah Carey on her diva
floor if you were really paying
attention you might have even noticed
her playing a ballerina and one of the
scenes of the greatest showmen notice of
the same movie that starred Zac Efron
and zendaya so that is a pretty big deal
for a girl her age the rest of the team
includes cutie Hannah Colin the adorable
Presley hot spot the gorgeous Sarah
Georgiana the talented Savannah Sue and
of course the fierce Brady Farrar who
will be having no trouble keeping up
with the ladies Mady is going to be the
first voice of a comment of
and starring member of The Dance Moms
cast this ultra-competitive team is
going to make for some great
entertainment and I just can't wait to
see what they bring to the table a few
thoughts I have on the upcoming season
is that we will probably be seeing some
of our favorite originals be back for a
few episodes at a time like some dancers
have done in the past my guess is that
we will definitely be seeing more of
Eliana and Macy once begin to clear
their schedules and finish up all their
other entertainment contracts it looks
like Abby has been spending a ton of
time with our favorite starlet here at
the thanks Jojo serie telling me that
there might be a chance we'll even see
it on the upcoming season if you've seen
some of JoJo's latest vlogs you'll know
that dance skills have gotten a bit
rusty but it's nothing that her bubbly
personality and star quality can't make
up for I wouldn't count on her leaving
Los Angeles for too long though since
she's already got an enormous YouTube
channel to keep up with what I hope
won't be happening in the upcoming
season is another set of two competing
teams like we saw with the minis I would
much rather prefer to see all of these
dancers dance together what do you guys
think it was also pretty cool watching
Kalani teach some choreo to the minis
back in the previous season so I would
definitely love to see her or Kendall
come back and teach some choreo to the
new squad I cannot wait for the show to
start filming which Abby has officially
confirmed will be the end of January and
I will definitely be part of the
millions of fans tuning and shamelessly
and loving every second of it be sure to
let me know in the comments section what
your predictions are I think it's safe
to say that we are all definitely happy
for Abby's recovery and cannot wait to
meet the new stars she's about to me
it's your Eleanor and don't forget to
hit me up on social media and feel free
to even let me know what you guys would
like us to cover next see you guys in
our next video
[Music]